warum liebe mir wer wir sind oder wärme
sind und obwohl mir ständig von anderen
dank über all die jahre oder die zu mir
extrem viel erfahrungen und eindrücken
neues und viel erlaubnis und sachen wo
es ab regen tvo der zugibt dass mir
alles weiterentwickelt oder hast du denn
macht es mir sind oder wer mir sind sind
alles so prozess wohl nur die sache hat
rosanna für sich selber immer wieder
bringt oder sachen wo vielleicht mal
negativ sie sind bewusst trotzdem carb
ist gut zu seiner fsg später oder für
den moment aber im endeffekt danke
bliebe mir definitiv anders
das ist für mich ich versuche immer noch
in die beste version familie oder zweite
mich sehr gut entwickelt auch für mich
und für meine persönlichkeit mit
charakter das sind alles punkte wo
system entstand was mir erlaubt